today on the matt welsh show as yet
another sex abuse scandal in golf's yet
another public school system an nbc news
op-ed argues that parents should stop
involving themselves in educational
matters because to intrude in schools is
like interfering with your child's
surgery they say it's a terrible analogy
but also revealing we'll talk about that
speaking of nbc an msnbc reporter was
caught
following the written house jury home
after deliberations what does it take to
get a mistrial exactly and students at
slu have started a petition to stop me
from speaking on campus in a couple
weeks so i started my own petition to
stop them from stopping me from speaking
on campus it's the battle of the
petitions and right now i'm winning in a
landslide i got to say we'll talk about
all that and a whole lot more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
well as all of my uh listeners and
viewers know i am something of a fashion
expert even a fashion guru as many
people have have labeled me and that's
why i want to tell you about mac weldon
whether it's an office party a party
with family and friends or just a
holiday party uh of you your couch and a
game on tv mac weldon has all the
essentials to keep you stylish and
comfortable throughout the season and
their innovative innovative daily wear
system that daily wire system a daily
wear system has taken the hard work out
of outfit planning with pieces designed
to work together for any occasion saving
you time and sparing you any extra
holiday stress not only that but mack
weldon's ace sweatshirts and sweatpants
and warm knit collection make fantastic
holiday gifts as well and no one is
doing better gift sets this holiday than
mac weldon with limited edition color
drops and a bevy of new releases their
holiday gift sets are the perfect
present for any guy on your list and i
hear the color drops are really
spectacular i wouldn't know as you know
because i am in the colorblind community
but either way you got to check out mac
weldon and for 20 off your first order
visit macweldon.com walsh and enter
promo code walsh that's macweldon.com
slash walls promote walls for 20 off mac
weldon get it right this holiday season
all right so it's a packed show today
it's a lot to talk about but we'll start
with this you know it's hard to keep
track of all of the scandals and
controversies engulfing the public
school system at the moment and it's not
that it's not that things have suddenly
gotten this bad it's that parents are
finally starting to notice how bad it is
and has been for many years this is a
reckoning and it's a long time coming
the north kingston school district in
rhode island has entered the foreground
in recent weeks as uh as all manner of
abuses have come to light here's the
local fox affiliate in rhode island with
a report on just one of their scandals
and this one is really bad
it says over more than two decades as
the boys basketball coach at north
kingston high school aaron thomas was
widely respected for success on the
court culminating in the school's first
ever state championship of 2019. yet
within two years of the victorious
season thomas was out at north kingston
high quietly taking a new job at a
middle school in a neighboring town
school officials made no announcement
about the celebrated coach's departure
until last week when thomas was put on
administrative leave at his new school
after the attorney general's office
confirmed it was investigating his
behavior as a coach a month-long
investigation by target 12 discovered
the reason for thomas's abrupt fall from
grace
former student-athletes had come forward
to accuse thomas of making them meet
meet him behind closed doors and strip
naked
behavior they said he engaged in for
years
we're then given some details about how
these uh what exactly happened this was
all part of a quote-unquote fat test
that the
coach would administer
and um
here's how those were carried out it
said once naked the coach would instruct
the teenagers to perform stretches sit
cross-legged in front of him and allow
him to use a caliper to pinch and
measure their body fat according to
documents obtained by target 12 as well
as interviews with 10 former students
parents and town officials who spoke on
the condition of anonymity two others uh
sent emails to target 12 detailing
similar experiences the people who spoke
about their experiences had either
played for thomas as students or were
parents of children who played for him
over a period of time stretching from
the early 2000s to as recently as 2019.
some played sports other others
other than basketball
one former player said after i grew up i
started asking some real questions about
what had happened did i need to be naked
as part of its investigation target 12
contacted five professional personal
trainers each said it is unnecessary to
be naked for such a test
now
after remaining silent about all of this
for weeks the superintendent this week
finally addressed the issue
at a school board meeting claiming that
he he handled everything properly and
appropriately now again this this guy
was
he he left the high school
and was sent to go work at a middle
school instead
but parents of the district they say
otherwise they say this was not handled
appropriately they claimed that there
was a cover-up much like what we saw in
loudoun county
and there's no dispute that parents and
and the public were not told about any
of this until it was reported in the
media
just like loudoun county
the school system now says that it
couldn't alert the public because of
quote unquote privacy concerns they
would have liked to tell everybody but
they had to worry about privacy
meanwhile as this is going on parents in
the district in the very same district
have also uncovered pornographic
material
which has been made available to
children in the district
apparently down into the elementary
school ages
one is a now familiar book called
genderqueer which apparently enjoys wide
distribution in schools all across the
country because we've seen outrage over
this book
all across the country the other is a
graphic novel called fun home
now both of these
books
depict graphic scenes of sex between
teenagers
the superintendent has again defended
himself on this one also arguing that
these reading materials are intended to
promote quote sexual health among kids
now by now it's clear that promote
sexual health is just a fancier way of
saying grooming
and this is why parents are involving
themselves and what democrats would say
is the school's business
parents don't trust the schools
they suspect that the schools have plans
and intentions for their children that
fall far outside
of the proper academic realm
and they're right of course
democrats are flailing around trying to
explain why the parental drive to
protect and defend their children is
somehow sinister
now in fairness to the democrats on this
point
they've staked out a position on
education that is impossible to
intelligibly defend
you cannot really blame them i guess for
their bad arguments as there are those
are the only sorts of arguments
available to them given the position
they've taken
the claim that the state ought to have
unquestioned authority to teach children
whatever it wants to groom them in
whatever way it wants
and that parents who try to offer their
two cents are infiltrators at best and
terrorists at worst
is not one that can be supported on
either logical or moral grounds
still from a from a menu of disagreeable
talking points
they seem to always choose the stupidest
and most repugnant options
so stupid and repugnant in fact that
they tend to make the opposition's
argument for us so case in point
an nbc news op-ed published last night
from left-wing author and journalist
christina wyman and here's the headline
schools face parents who want to ban
critical race theory and don't get how
teaching works
stupid parents they don't understand how
teaching works
it begins like this parents and
politicians across the country are
interfering with the curricula that
public schools use to teach to students
state legislatures are passing laws to
keep critical race theory out of schools
literary classics like toni morrison's
the bluest eye are banned for sexual
content and school libraries are coming
under attack for uh containing books
about gender there are even parents who
are trying to shield students from
learning about mental health and suicide
as though helping children build
emotional fortitude is a bad thing
and then things really go off the rails
she says parents have always tried to
interfere with curricula as i observed
when teaching middle school in the
mid-2000s even then there was no
shortage of parental input about the
content of my instruction from books to
test questions
part of the problem is that parents
think they have the right to control
teaching and learning because their
children are the ones being educated but
it actually gasp doesn't work that way
it's sort of like entering a surgical
unit thinking you can interfere with a
num with an operation
simply because the patient is your child
no it's it's not sort of like that at
all i mean that analogy is sort of like
the stuff that comes out of the back end
of a cow for one thing
parents do indeed
have an enormous amount of say over what
sort of medical procedures their kids
undergo the left of course is trying to
erode those rights as well which partly
explains why she chose to make this
comparison in the first place for
another
teaching grade school
is not nearly the sort of specialized
complex skill
that is performing surgery
teachers are not surgeons
if we require that sort of
specialization and qualification and
intelligence from teachers there
wouldn't be enough teachers to man the
assembly lines at these educational
factories
for still another
medicine is or should be
mostly objective right if a child has a
tumor the tumor has to be removed
now depending on the sickness and the
medical intervention that's recommended
you might get different opinions from
different medical professionals but you
are at the end of the day
dealing with the physical body which has
certain physical needs that the doctors
are supposed to be tending to
but education is concerned with a deeper
question
what sort of people
do we want our children to be
how should they be formed morally and
intellectually what shape should they
take
i mean you could see why a doctor would
ideally be the expert on what sort of
medicine to give a child
even there it's not unquestioned by any
means
but you could see how they
ideally would be the expert on that i
know what kind of surgery to perform
but why should a public school teacher
be an expert on what sort of person your
child ought to be
why would the state be the authority on
that subject
finally and this is really what it comes
down to i think
kids in school are not sick okay they're
not sick people in need of treatment
we don't send them to school to be
healed
but that is indeed how the left views
the situation for all of their talk
about the separation of church and state
the way they see it the state school is
a church
and the children in its care are in need
of spiritual healing
things like the pornographic books
certainly critical race theory gender
theory all of this that's all part of
the treatment plan
and we should get out of the way
and let our children be healed they say
but we absolutely shouldn't listen to
that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well two questions for you do you like
saving money and do you like to do
things when they're easy to do or in
other words are you lazy um if the
answer to both of those is yes as it is
for me then i've got what you need get
upside the get upside app uh because
look with the get upside app you can
save 25 cents for every gallon of this
get 25 cents back for every gallon of
gas that you pump every time you fill up
just download the free get upside app in
the app store or google play right now
use promo code walsh while you're there
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents a
gallon uh cash back for your first fill
up and then you still get the 25 cents
thereafter but just you know you'd have
to pay full price of the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free it is
completely free use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cash back on
your first tank
and uh how do you get the money out well
it's really simple they send it to your
bank account they can send it through
paypal you can even cash out with uh
like an e gift card for amazon or
something like that it's easy to do
you're saving money it is all upside no
downside just download the free get
upside app and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cash back on
your first tank that's code walsh okay
so the written house
jury went home for a third night without
a verdict last night
went home okay they they went back to
their homes because they haven't been
sequestered through any any portion of
this even during the deliberations
which is which is just one of the things
that's completely crazy about everything
we we've seen happen with this trial
why does sequestering a jury why why is
that an option that exists in the first
place if it's not going to be used in a
situation like this just like it wasn't
used with the derek chauvin trial and i
can remember on this show screaming
uh until my face was blue about that as
well
why why wouldn't you what's the argument
against sequestering the jury
and once again why is that an option if
we're not using it for a trial like this
the the car written house murder trial
is one of the most high profile
contentious explosive murder trials in
modern american history
and it's it's it is happening amid
protests and people threatening to
threatening violence and writing and
everything else
and that doesn't warrant sequestering
the jury
you just send them home at the end of
the day and say well don't don't talk to
anybody
don't don't do that
wag your finger at them tell them don't
talk to anybody
don't consult anything any resources
don't go online
well we know for a fact
that um
the instruction that they're not
supposed to consult any resources when
they're you know not deliberating we
know that's not being followed because
last night the judge allowed one of the
jurors to bring the um
the the jury instructions home with her
and it's like 30 pages of instructions
and she was allowed to bring it home
which
it would seem to me as a non-legal
expert it would that would seem to be
the sort of thing that you can't allow
because you're bringing you know
all of the jury deliberations and
reading the instructions and all of that
stuff that's supposed to happen during
the deliberations you can't bring that
home with you this you can't have a this
is not a homework assignment situation
but the judge refused to sequester the
jury um he's refused to to up to this
point to call a mistrial
even though he said in open court he
said
that a grave constitutional violation
was committed
while the prosecution was making its
case he said that no mistrial
we know now that the prosecution
withheld evidence from the defense no
mistrial
and now we also know
that uh msnbc
sent a reporter well they say they
didn't send him
but an msnbc reporter an msnbc employee
was
in the vicinity was uh was was you know
apparently following the bus with the
jurors home last night
and still no mistrial for this
and the judge doesn't seem all that
upset about it but here he is uh
yesterday revealing this um
this information about msnbc
um
a person who identified himself as james
j morrison
and who claimed that he was a producer
with nbc news
and played uh for msnbc
um
and under the supervision
of a person
what's going on
oh okay uh under the supervision of
someone named irene bion in new york
uh for msnbc
uh the police when they stopped him
because he was following in a distance
of about
a black and uh went through a red light
pulled him over and inquired of him what
was going on and he
gave that information
and stated that he had been instructed
by ms bion
in new york to
follow the jury bus
okay so he
this was someone with him
with msnbc who said that he was told to
follow the jury bus home
um yeah another reason why you probably
shouldn't be sending them home
i know there there's some people on the
right especially seem to really like
this judge
i don't like him um i i think he seems
like sort of a doddering old
fool who's not who's not
up to the task here
just kind of rambling his way through
this thing
and uh
and as i said he should have called a
mistrial about there's about five or six
different reasons to call it
and he hasn't
and he did ban msnbc from the courtroom
but there's not
even with this
there's not the sort of urgency around
this situation that there ought to be
when you've got
in a in a in a trial like this
where we can already assume
that the the jurors are worried about
backlash and everything and now we know
the media is following them home
ought to be a lot more urgency around
that than we just saw there
now msnbc they
put out a statement
a couple hours after all this was
revealed
and this is supposedly a statement
denying but um it's not really a denial
it's more of an it's really a confession
within the framework of a denial so
here's what they say
last night a freelancer received a
traffic citation while the traffic
violation took place near the jury van
the freelancer never contacted or
intended to contact the jurors during
deliberations
and never photographed or intended to
photograph them
huh
so yeah he happened to be i mean we just
had our reporter we had one of our guys
a freelancer he happened to be he just
so happened to get this um
traffic violation right next to the jury
event it's a coincidence but but he he
never intended to contact the jurors
during deliberations
okay
those
there's there's two words there that's
that's a really important qualification
because if msnbc
never intended to contact the jurors
period then that's what they would say
no never intended to contact them during
deliberations
what he wanted to do was find out who
they are get their identities find out
where they live so that after the
deliberations um the media could contact
them
and if they come down with a not guilty
verdict the media could dox them
that was the intention so this is all
but a confession from the way that it's
that it's
framed but no mistrial we're just going
to carry on
like that didn't happen
carry on as if the constitutional the
um grave constitutional violation never
occurred carry on as if the defense had
not withheld evidence
carry on as if the media is not
following the jurors home
and as if by the way they're not aware
that that is happening
because you're sending them home
where they could easily be exposed and
i'm sure they are being exposed to media
and everything so they know that they're
being followed by the media
not only that but even you know even
kyle rittenhouse's defense
not to monday morning morning
quarterback this thing but uh it's not
quite monday morning in terms of the
trial
but even his his defense lawyers
don't seem to have the urgency
that they ought to have
you know as as a layman as a layman
watching this
um it doesn't seem to me like they're
really fighting for their client as
forcefully as they ought to be given
what is happening
given what we're all witnessing
this is one of the great miscarriages of
justice that we've ever seen
ever that any of us have ever seen in
our lifetimes
in the court system
unfolding right now
and it's like
you know even even the defense that
they don't seem to care as much as they
ought to that's just my
my perspective on it i could be maybe
i'm misinterpreting but
meanwhile out on the steps of the uh of
the courthouse
where all the protesters are gathered
we've been seeing some scenes like this
so first um a couple days ago the
protesters on both sides
were uh they were they they shared a
pizza so they ordered some dominoes and
they were sitting
here's the video and this was this was
being shared on twitter and people were
saying this is nice they're
finding common ground they're sharing a
pizza
uh and here they are eat eating uh
eating a meal together breaking bread
this is but this is supposed to be
inspiring i guess
that they can all sit together and then
and then both sides
sat down and had some pizza
and then the very next day
um the uh so some police officers were
there
and they were giving out cookies to the
to the protesters and i think they were
calling it cookies for peace there it is
giving out cookies too isn't that nice
cookies for peace i mean these are all
the you know let's give let's give
cookies to the potential rioters and
maybe that'll convince them
not to burn down the city
again come on boys and girls come get
some cookies okay if you want cookies
you can't burn down the city all right
burn down the city no more cookies
i i you know i'm sorry but i'm not very
inspired by this or the pizza thing i
have to tell you
i know that we're supposed to find
common ground and all that kind of stuff
but
when when you've got
uh
people
who are demanding that an innocent man
go to prison
because he defended himself
against arsonists and child rapists who
are trying to kill him
you know when you've got people
demanding that that man
has a blood sacrifice be sent to prison
for the rest of his life
no that's i i don't want to share a
pizza with you
i don't i don't want to share common
ground there is no common ground
i don't even want to share a country
with
you and sitting down for 30 minutes and
posing for cameras pretending like we
have anything in common whatsoever
pretending like we respect each other
i'm not sure what the point of that is
because all those people the blm
you know protesters and everything
having the pizza and acting very
friendly if they don't get their way
they'll happily go out and loot and burn
and attack you in the street and stomp
on your head
there is no there is no common ground
there see in order to have common ground
and have unity
like i talk about all the time
um there has to be some common ground
first of all you have to have some basic
things in common but also there has to
be respect i mean there has to be some
amount some element of of basic respect
between people
in order in order for there to be any
hope of of of
of peace and unity and all that great
stuff
and i like the idea of peace and unity
as an idea
but the problem is i can't respect you
if you're on that side of it
you know a man goes to kenosha to stop
rioters from to tr to do his part to try
to stop rioters
from uh from from committing all this
violence and destruction
and next thing you know he's under
attack and he has to defend himself
and you want to put him in jail for the
rest of his life i i cannot respect you
at all on any level
i don't respect you as a man i don't
respect you as an american i don't
respect your point of view
i don't respect any of it
how can i
it is not respectable by definition
all right let's go to this um
i'm supposed to be speaking at st louis
university on december 1st and this has
apparently been a subject of great
controversy on campus for weeks now
and you know some of the leftist groups
on campus they don't want me to speak
they're terrified of what i might say
and they now have a petition it's the
keep matt walsh off of st louis
university campus petition it's on
change.org so if you uh feel the same
way with them i mean you could go find
the petition and sign it
it's addressed to the president of the
school in the administration and uh let
me read a little bit of this petition it
says conservative speakers have visited
our campus previously without issue
political discourse is valuable and
arguably necessary to our college
education
are
arguably necessary
but matt walsh is not simply a
conservative speaker he is a threat to
women to lgbtqia plus community and
racial minorities on campus
his twitter is one example of his
dangerous persona
uh
it's i can think of a better
advertisement for my twitter page i
guess that's my my dangerous persona on
twitter
um he says uh as you can read from his
social media matt walsh holds extremely
controversial and harmful opinions
for example he calls feminism rotten at
the core and one of the worst things to
ever happen to western civilization
yeah i mean my only qualification there
my only clarification i suppose i should
say is that um i would probably argue
it's not one of the worst things to
happen to western civilization uh it may
indeed be the worst thing to ever happen
in a western civilization but
uh he responds to his dissenters by
calling them stupid and morally deranged
true i do i i do in fact well i only if
you're stupid and morally deranged then
i will observe that fact i'll point that
out i can't be blamed for that
he says gender theory is by far the
biggest threat in our schools
these extreme statements allow no room
for healthy conversations instead they
promote dangerous stereotypes allowing
matt walsh to speak on campus is not
representative of the jesuit education
we have received in our years at slu
well i can't argue with that
i would be quite offended if anyone ever
accused me
of saying anything that is um
in keeping with or representative of uh
jesuits
furthermore hate speech galvanizes
people matt walsh will potentially be on
campus for a few hours but his speech
will last more than a few hours for his
supporters his words will become a tool
to advance their discriminatory behavior
etc etc and so on and so it goes on for
a while the petition got about 1400
signatures in two days so you know not
too bad i'll say
so then i decided to make my own
petition um instead of to keep matt
walsh off of st louis university campus
petition i made the keep matt walsh on
st louis university campus petition and
here's what mine says i'll read you mine
it's a it's a lot shorter
i said we the undersign believe that slu
administrators should not cave to the
leftist demand to shut down the upcoming
matt walsh talk this campaign is driven
by ignorance cowardice fear and
stupidity it represents everything that
institution of higher learning
particularly a catholic institution
should oppose if ideas such as women
don't have penises and it's wrong to
kill babies are not welcome on campus
then slu will have declared itself to be
nothing but a radical far-left religious
cult it will have sacrificed truth and
free expression on the progressive altar
and it will have done all of this in a
fruitless and ultimately self-defeating
attempt to appease a deranged
ideological horde that cannot be
appeased no matter how much it is
coddled we demand more of slu stand for
truth and freedom not fear and moral
insanity thank you
p.s spg forever
i had to throw that in there at the end
i couldn't help myself
so we got twice as many signatures in 30
minutes than they got in two days which
is pretty great and we're now up to what
are we up to we're up to uh over 13 000
signatures um and if you want to add
your name to our petition to keep me on
the campus
then we'll put a link in the description
on youtube and you can sign it there or
you can find it posted on my social
media if you're not listening on youtube
right now
um and you know already with 13 000
signatures
far more than they were able to get with
much more time to do it
it's clear that the people have already
spoken
and so if slu cancels me now it will be
i think we could say an attack on
democracy um
it would even be an insurrection
in many ways deeply troubling
i also want to be clear about one other
thing here
this is not simply a matter of
free speech
okay or a diversity of ideas that's
that's not what
that's not what this is about it's not
merely that anyway
okay i'm not saying that they should
allow me to speak on slu which again is
a catholic campus allegedly
i'm not saying that they should do it
just for the sake of diversity of ideas
what makes it outrageous that they're
trying to keep me off of campus
it's not that my ideas are different
it's that my ideas are right
okay and that is
really an important point
it is it should need to be said but it
does it is worse
to try to keep right opinions and rights
statements and ideas off of your campus
than to keep wrong ones
now we could have an argument if i was
getting up there and saying a whole
bunch of wildly fantastic and wrong
things
should they still allow me well yeah i
think you could make that argument that
that they should
for the sake of a diversity of ideas and
letting people express different
opinions and letting you know the
students be exposed to different to
different viewpoints
um and all of that
but that's not what i'm doing
what i'm saying is true
and so that's my number one argument for
why i should be allowed on the campus
because what i'm saying is true and not
only that but you're a catholic campus
and if you have students on a catholic
campus
who you know are not only pro-abortion
but are offended at the very idea
that anybody could be pro-life
don't even want to be anywhere near that
that point of view
then something is terribly wrong with
your school and your institution
you know that you've created an
environment
on a catholic campus where your students
feel entitled
to be um
to be to be to be insulated
from viewpoints that are not only true
but also totally in keeping with
catholic teaching
okay that should be a problem for you
you should see that as a problem if
you're an administrator at slu
that your students you've
apparently created an environment where
your students feel entitled to be
insulated
from catholic teaching
which everything that i say is
is in keeping with catholicism
and it's also right again
so i think we really understand what are
they really upset about
they say it there
um one of their big
one of the big problems is my my
criticism of feminism
why do i criticize feminism well for a
lot of reasons but the number one thing
is that feminism has led to the deaths
of 60 million babies
which i think is why you could you could
you could certainly make an argument
that it is the worst thing to ever
happen to western civilization there has
never been an ideology or a movement
that has been more deadly than feminism
with 60 million dead human beings
um they're also upset about my criticism
of gender theory as i say in my petition
you know i believe that women don't have
penises and that only women give birth
so we would be really we would really be
understating the problem
if we said that uh
keeping me off of campus is simply an
attack on the diversity of ideas
it's it's not simply that
they want to keep me off of campus
because i believe that only women can
give birth
these are college students
who want to be protected from basic
biological truths and basic moral truths
that's what makes this so absurd and
insane and outrageous and why you
absolutely cannot cave to it
all right
next
from cnn oklahoma governor kevin stitt
has uh granted clemency to julius jones
commuting jones death sentence just
hours before he was scheduled to be
executed for a 1999
1999 murder that he says he did not
commit
jones sentence will be commuted to life
in prison without the possibility of
parole
the republican governor came to the
decision following prayerful
consideration and reviewing materials
presented by all sides of the case
this had become a major cause
kim kardashian got involved and said
that you know
we can't execute julius jones and uh
there was there was there was really
people on the left and right i think
cpac also
interceded on behalf of julius jones and
finally the republican governor cave to
it and said all right we're not going to
execute him
a couple of things here
first of all despite what you may have
heard about this case
there is dna evidence
eyewitness testimony
and a murder weapon
all convicting him
if that's not beyond a reasonable doubt
then then what is i mean how can you
ever find anybody guilty of anything
if that's not enough eyewitness
testimony dna and a murder weapon
if they were missing one of those three
then you could always say all right well
maybe there's some reasonable doubt here
there's at least
you have you have something to hang your
hat on at least when it comes to a
reasonable doubt
in this case you don't
you've got the big three eyewitness dna
and murder weapon they found the murder
weapon in his home
so this is beyond a reasonable doubt
that he's guilty
and in fact
the fact that he's not being let out
means not being pardoned he's not having
his whole his entire sentence commuted
he's uh he's
it's just being converted to rather than
execution life without the possibility
of parole
and that means that the governor doesn't
think he's innocent
so then why change the punishment
also why why should a public pressure
campaign why should activism convince
you
either you think the evidence is solid
and he's guilty or you don't
you know if you think that he was
falsely convicted then he should be out
of prison i mean if this is a this is a
matter of
he might actually be innocent of these
charges if you think there's reason to
believe that
then why are you giving him life without
the possibility of pearl he should be
out on the street right now
but if he was convicted legitimately
which he was
then he murdered a man in cold blood in
front of his child and should face the
consequences
you know compassion for killers should
not override justice
and what is justice justice is giving
people what they are due
um it is not just despite what some of
the students on slu campus think it is
not just to kill babies in the womb
because they are not due that treatment
they don't deserve that they don't
warrant it
and when you think about it in those
terms there's just no way to justify
abortion
that's why pro-aborts they ignore the
baby's existence entirely in their
arguments about abortion they just
they try to make
they make this argument about abortion
while ignoring the baby but what what
are we arguing about when it comes to
abortion we're arguing about what we
should do with this baby that exists
and if you're saying that that um
the baby should be
killed or terminated to yours use your
terminology
then i will ask
why does the baby
deserve that
why does the baby warrant that treatment
and if you have no response to that if
you cannot tell me why a baby
let's put aside bodily autonomy and all
these all the arguments about what's all
the arguments about the woman let's put
that aside for a moment
because there are two people involved
here
and let's focus on the baby for just a
second
you think the baby the quote unquote
fetus should be terminated
does
does does the the human in the womb
does he warrant that treatment is he do
that treatment
and if you cannot say yes to that
then there's no way that you can justify
abortion
now on the other hand um
a man
a grown man who makes a decision to call
to kill another man in cold blood
is he do
execution does he warrant that
has he done something that warrants that
is that justice
i would say it is
i mean this is a choice that you made
you made the decision that you don't
want to be a part of human society
anymore babies in the womb they haven't
made that decision
they're not given a choice
but when you go out
and you decide to commit this heinous
crime then that is a this that is a
statement you are making to society and
what you're saying to society is i don't
want to be a part of you anymore i don't
want to be a part of human society i
don't want to live like a civilized
human being
and once you have made that decision
once you have selected that fate for
yourself
then uh then
it is just to give you what you what you
quite literally asked for
to give you what you do
all right next we got jen pasake was
asked about the 100 000 drug overdose
deaths in a year in 2020 and uh why
biden isn't doing more to stop the drugs
from coming across the board in the
first place and she predictably did not
have a very good answer but here she is
grim milestone this week more than 100
000 people died of drug overdoses in the
last year experts say a lot of that is
driven by fentanyl which is coming
across the southern border in record
amounts so why is not why isn't the
administration doing more to stop the
drugs from coming in
well first i would say that the
president is meeting with the president
of mexico today as you know and that we
work with mexico every day to disrupt
transnational criminal organizations
which are responsible as you know for
the majority of fentanyl heroin and
methamphetamine entering the united
states as well as spreading violence and
insecurity in mexico so during the
summit today we certainly expect that
discussing this topic our joint goals to
combat transnational crime and terrorism
uh this the movement of of uh of these
type of drugs across the border would be
part of the discussion and when it
concludes we'll provide a readout
um translation we aren't doing anything
because we don't care about americans
you know that that's the real
translation
and when we talk about the drug overdose
epidemic as we discussed yesterday 100
000 americans in a year it's
unfathomable
numbers that we're talking about
um
how do we solve that problem well one of
those ways
is
as mentioned there to stop the drugs
from coming coming across the border
um
but also i go back to something i
mentioned
yesterday you know the pharmaceutical
industry carries a lot of a lot of the
blame
because an increase in prescription pill
overdoses is part of this story
and this should really be a bipartisan
issue
you know this this should this should be
there there are not very many issues
where there where there even could be
bipartisan agreement but this is one
where there ought to be
um here's one thing that um that we
should all be able to rally around
direct-to-consumer pharmacy ads
okay because like i said yesterday with
with the the directive to consumer
pharmaceutical advertisements
um everything is being
taken out of order here because the way
it's supposed to go is you have a
symptom you go to the doctor
you tell them your symptoms the doctor
is again supposed to be the expert on
this
and and then they can recommend a
treatment plan
you don't go to the
doctor with the diagnosis and treatment
already in mind because you got it from
tv
but that's the any next time you hear
from any kind of drug ad on tv you'll
notice it's always the same they're
always it's always the same script it's
always do you have x symptoms then you
might have y disease good news there's
pharma dose talk to your doctor about
pharma dose today
and then a list of side effects that uh
takes up 98 of the total run time of the
commercial so this is one this is
actually one
policy actual substantive policy thing
that could be done
that would certainly not solve the drug
overdose epidemic but it would address
it
and it would make a dent in it in a very
profound way and that is banning those
kinds of ads
you know i didn't i don't care i know
there are some people on the right as oh
we can't we can't do anything like that
it's a tackle on a free market
um
the government also has a responsibility
to look out for
the good of its citizens the actual good
of its citizens
and when you have the this multi-billion
dollar pharmaceutical industry
which is selling disease
to its citizens then that's a time to
step in and i think those advertisements
ought to be banned all right finally uh
let's check in with a conversation on
the bbc i i just i love this
conversation for reasons that will
become quite clear to you in a moment a
discussion about trans issues where the
question the famous question is dropped
dropped when i say dropped i mean
dropped like a hot potato dropped to
avoid answering it but let's uh let's
listen to that these are views expressed
by rosie that are held by many in
society and yet they seem to be
unacceptable to express certainly in
some form why
well i think the first thing to say is
that the majority of women actually do
support transgender rights and they do
say that you know a trans woman is a
woman
um so actually it may be held by some in
society but it's not the majority view
and it's not the majority view of women
so i think that's the first thing to say
but what about the definition of woman
as by your biological sex rather than
your preferred gender identity you know
i actually don't know why some people
are women and why some people are men no
one on this panel does
and anyone who claims to know the answer
to that question is a liar
all i care about is the principle of
live and let live and showing one
another respect so if a person says
yes i was born a man but i am a woman
and this is how i live my life i want to
respect that person for who they are
because i don't think they're doing
anything wrong and they're certainly not
bothering me in any way so i think the
ultimate important principle here that
we should all share if we want a free
and accepting society is live and let
live
nobody nobody knows if you say you know
what makes a woman a woman then you're a
liar this is
i mean the entire everyone in the
literally everybody
in the world in the entire history of
the world forever
knew the answer to this question up
until uh 25 seconds ago but now it's
it's a mystery nobody knows nobody knows
no one can answer it
nobody can answer why a woman is a woman
and this this is a woman saying this
i'm a woman but i don't know why i don't
know what makes me a woman
um just a quick hit it's your female
reproductive system excess chromosomes
that's that's that's what does it
as far as the live and let live thing
though
i'm not going to get much into that
because our daily cancellation in fact
deals with this idea
that all they really want is just live
and let live people do let people do
what they want
that is not the case at all we'll get to
that in a minute but first the comment
section
do you know their name
user all the way left says omg the right
is saying that the left is freaking out
over a cartoon depicting a member of our
government killing another member of our
government and calling their outrage
over calling their outrage over that
theater but it was matt it was matt
freaking out and canceling sesame street
a children's show let's just be clear
about one thing the kids that watch
sesame street can't go get a vaccine on
their own they still need their parents
consent now if parents have said
children want to get their kids
vaccinated then that is their right and
none of matt walsh's business but back
to the outrage over a cartoon by the
left it's a bad thing if it's a bad
thing then the outrage of the right over
some muppets is downright pathetic okay
well a couple points here um
not everything is the same okay first of
all so it's it's it's possible to make a
complaint about
something related to
a cartoon or a fictional show
that doesn't mean that every complaint
that anyone makes about cartoons is
going to be legitimate
okay also i don't know if it's accurate
to say that i freaked out over sesame
street
it's more that i used that issue as an
opportunity and a platform to make jokes
about new jersey i think i squeezed
about five of them in there so i don't
know if you could call that freaking out
necessarily
and then the third thing also
is that with the sesame street thing
um this is stuff aimed at children
and so
uh whereas with the with the paul gosar
meme that was on twitter that was that
was making fun of aimed at whatever you
want to say an adult
okay and so i think
as an adult if somebody makes a mean
cartoon about you
then it's your responsibility to just
kind of deal with it like an adult and
we don't need to have you crying taking
up time in the middle midst of all these
crises in these ca in our in the country
we don't need you standing
in congress as aoc did
taking up everybody's time taking up
taxpayer time crying about them you're a
grown-up get over it okay i can say that
to you as an adult get the hell over it
you whiny baby
but with kids it's different their kids
they actually need to be protected and
they need
if we as adults are not advocating for
them
then nobody will because they can't
advocate for themselves
and so when i see the indoctrination of
children who are susceptible and
vulnerable
and
that's to me an entirely different
situation
so do you see the distinction kids
versus adults
um
tetsuo says as a pretty hardcore attack
on titan fan gosar making himself aaron
jaeger
might not have been the best idea that
dude has a very dark future
i know right i was just thinking that um
wait what's attack on titan is that the
thing from yesterday oh okay
uh
the nathan zachary says hey matt love
the show do you believe in bigfoot like
you do aliens please explain keep up the
good work i think we've talked about
this before in fact i'm sure that we
have talked about the bigfoot versus
alien
uh debate
uh no i don't put i would love to think
that bigfoot exists i want him to
exist because that would be a lot of fun
but my argument for aliens is that um
aliens live out in the universe right
and the universe is such an
incomprehensibly vast place that it
seems absurd to suggest that there isn't
any other life out there
on all those many billions and trillions
of planets that exist just in our galaxy
alone and then you add on the 100
billion galaxies that are in just the
known universe and it becomes even more
absurd to suggest that we're alone
whereas with bigfoot you're talking
about a theory where it's uh this you
know i guess mostly intelligent
species of man apes that live just like
in the woods basically in in some guy's
backyard in alabama
uh that to me
if if if they existed we would have very
very firm evidence of it i can see why
aliens how aliens might exist and we
would have no evidence of it we could
you know human civilization could come
and go and destroy itself without ever
finding any firm evidence of aliens
because they're so far away uh but with
bigfoot it's quite a different story
all right
tomlin says
wow that was some deadpan advertising
it's like matt's soul was being sucked
out while he promoted those companies
yeah sucked out of my body so that they
could go buy those products more like
my soul literally left my body i had an
out of body experience i was so excited
about the products and services of my
beloved sponsors
unfortunately then you're just left with
the soulless husk to do the ad reads and
that's i guess what you're picking up on
history is being made here at the daily
wire as the first to file suit against
the bind administration for their
unconstitutional vaccine mandates we're
pleased to see that the buy
administration suspended their
implementation and enforcement this week
this is huge for the freedom of american
workers to make their own medical
decisions as of the right without the
government's authoritarian hand getting
involved and we can't be happier to be
at the forefront of this fight against
joe biden's assault on our business on
our bodies on our private health
decisions on the constitution on
everything really however there are
plenty of businesses who are enforcing
mandates and our victory means nothing
really unless these businesses do the
right thing and stop it's understandable
that there's been enormous pressure from
the government to comply but there's
truly no reason now to do that to force
your employees to make a medical
decision that they don't feel
comfortable with because the mandate is
not in effect at the present moment and
if you're an employee and your company
is forcing this nonsense on you there's
no longer a reason for you to have to do
that either they cannot force you to
take a vaccine you don't want to take
don't let them hide behind the vaccine
mandate unless we lose none of this
will apply and there's no reason to
comply and we're not going to comply but
the fight is just getting started we
still have to win the court case so sign
our petition against bindin's biden's
vaccine mandate over at dailywire.com
do not comply to send a message to the
obama administration that americans
don't
do whatever they're told especially when
it's being told to us by tyrants like
biden we have over 600 000 people who
have signed the petition so far and the
more signatures we get the louder the
message that's why we're aiming to get
to one million signatures so head to
dailywire.com do not comply to sign the
petition today and also
this isn't your last chance to sign up
for my highly lauded newsletter you
could really do that any time but it is
your last time the last time i'm going
to tell you about the precious banjo
that i am giving away this is your last
chance to win that your subscription to
the newsletter will automatically enter
you into the running to claim the banjo
which has been sitting behind me all the
while which i have played beautiful
music on every single day i play it um
and it can be yours that banjo can be
yours all you have to do is sign up for
the newsletter and in order to do that
go to dailywire.com banjo to subscribe
to my newsletter which is always uh full
of the best writing that you'll read all
week and work
it's the most random giveaway
a banjo giveaway for a newsletter that's
what we're doing there's no there's no
turning back now we can so go to
dailywire.com
banjo now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so this was a uh such a stupid week
chock full of so much maniacal idiocy
that it was difficult to select only one
candidate for the friday cancellation in
fact i had other plans for this segment
but at the last moment in a dramatic
finish today's cancelling surged ahead
and crossed the finish line kathy hokul
is the new governor of new york and she
wins the honor today she'll be canceled
uh by me today but but it's nothing
personal against her i actually
appreciate how hard she's worked to
prove me right
because i said during the cuomo scandal
once it became clear that the democrats
had abandoned him and were ready to sell
him up the river
that they would not be taking that step
if they didn't have someone even more
extreme waiting in the wings
little was known about hockey at the
time her career has been marked only by
mediocrity having made a living as a
kind of full-time political default
option she's the camila harris of new
york in other words but despite knowing
nothing about her the fact that she was
the hitter on deck
while cuomo was left to flail around
helplessly in the batter's box was
enough to confirm that she is either a
died in the wool leftist or enough of a
hollowed-out shell of a human being has
to be reliably counted on to do the
bidding of the radical left in her case
i suspect the second option gets closer
to the truth whichever is the case she
has taken over for the disgraced grandma
killer though somehow the grandma
killing is not what makes him disgraced
and set to work in stating the kind of
wilkified policies that were even too
far for cuomo
case in point this week hockey signed a
bill making it illegal for utility
companies to misgender or dead name
trans people
that is the bill makes it illegal for
employees of utility companies to speak
biological truths in reference to or in
the presence of
gender confused individuals
the website gay city news a trusted
source of gay news for city dwellers has
more has more on this it says the bill
quote
requires utility waterworks and phone
companies to recognize the pronouns and
names of ex of customers ex-governor
andrew cuomo had faced pressure over the
summer from dozens of groups of lgbt
people who were pushing him to sign the
bill known as the affirming gender
identity in utilities act
advocates had stressed that the bill
would prevent customers from being
misgendered dead named or otherwise
targeted by traumatic forms of
discrimination furthermore customers
looking to update their names and
pronouns with companies have encountered
requirements to produce court orders to
show their information
and that's gone too now because of the
bill
now given that utility bills are one of
the most common forms of identification
accepted by dmvs and other government
agencies what could possibly go wrong
now that anybody can change their name
and sex without having to produce any
documentation of any kind
well quite a lot could go wrong but
kathy hopkins isn't worried about any of
that she's worried about flashing her
leftist credentials which for the modern
democrat is the entire point and purpose
of the office
governing is nothing but a succession of
virtue signals
it's also an opportunity to radically
transform and deform our nation and
culture but that's more of a nice
secondary bonus for the empty shell
types like hokule
but to hear her tell it
she's been deeply invested in the trans
rights issue for many years
indeed it is the cause nearest and
dearest to her heart she wakes up every
morning with but one thought on her mind
how can she cater to less than one
percent of the population today at the
expense of the other 99
well here she is further explaining that
and her decision to sign the bill
this is what we just call
common sense legislation that is long
overdue
for a transgender individual being
misgendered
it's traumatic
these are people with feelings and
individuals who just deserve more than
that and to know that this is going on
and causing them anguish
therefore it causes me anguish this is
how i feel so deeply and passionately
about the people of the state we have an
opportunity to bring back new york city
new york state we value individuals we
value people and we show love
respect and dignity to all it's that
simple and i know we can do this
[Music]
yes uh it causes the poor woman anguish
to think about the trauma suffered by a
trans person who's forced to hear their
own name or a biologically appropriate
pronoun repeated back to them
you can look at kathy's eyes and see the
pain in her soul or you would be able to
see if she had a soul
she calls this common sense legislation
that will help bring back new york state
apparently the only thing holding new
york back are utility company employees
calling their non-binary pansexual
customers he and her instead of z and
zer it's simply common sense to babble
nonsensically and deny physical reality
if somebody in the lgbt community
community says that you should
life is one big game of simon says and
lgbt people are forever the simons
common sense you see
not only that but it's respectful of
their feelings
well what about the feelings of utility
company workers who now must endure the
humiliation of being forced to speak
untruths and use gibberish or else lose
their job
what about those who are being subjected
to a compelled speech mandate but would
quite prefer to retain their first
amendment rights instead
do their feelings carry any way
if it would make you feel good for me to
participate in your delusion
but it would make me feel bad to
participate do we not need something
other than feelings to settle this
dilemma
in a world of sanity and justice we
would but then again in such a world we
wouldn't need to have this conversation
in the first place in the real world
though the world we actually live in
the democrat party has decided that
strangers must be legally compelled to
affirm and reinforce an individual's
self-perception
now there was a time not all that long
ago like even you know just like five
minutes ago we heard on bbc when live in
let live was allegedly the motto
but now it's not nearly enough to let
people live as they please you must
actively participate
in their lifestyle choice
you know we went from
just let them be
to you must celebrate
and we've gone beyond that now now it's
you have to participate in it
you must be an active participant
their self-identification is your charge
it's your warrant
it's a it is a fragile delicate thing
their identity which you are legally
obligated to protect and reinforce
but if it's a real identity and if
they're sure of it
why should it require your involvement
why should there need to be a literal
gun to your head forcing you to assent
to it
and anyway how does the government have
any right to do any of this
where does it derive the authority to
legally mandate that one private
individual affirmed the
self-identification of another private
individual
from the democrats the answer to all of
these questions is as always who cares
we'll do what we want
and that's kathy hopkins answer whether
she says it or not
and it's why i must say to her finally
today you're canceled
and something tells me not for the last
time
we'll leave it there for today and for
the week have a great weekend talk to
you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin